let's go
another one roll the cameras
we're gonna go with d4
we're gonna go with another positional
opening here
and uh
uh
my
president
would play c4
i don't even know if this is bush or
clinton anyways um i
did not have relations with that woman
[Music]
now e6 is is a move and this offers a
transposition to the french but if
you're a d4 player you're under no
obligation to play e4
um and you can play this just as you
would against any other move against
knight f6 or d5 you can just play c4 and
this is very high transpositional
potential so black and transposed to a
queen's gambit
this is not a transposition to anything
i've never seen this move before some
sort of weird benko gambit b5 so this is
going to be a good lesson in combating
obscure off-beat openings
okay now obviously we should take that
pawn i mean i don't know what he's gonna
what he's gonna do i guess okay d5
maybe he looked up some line i don't
really know thank you andras 34 people
this is incredibly strange it's some
sort of a pawn sacrifice i've never seen
this before
and
hey zvyad good to see you
um
and honestly
there isn't anything special that you
should do here you should just develop
your pieces and you shouldn't spend too
long agonizing over why is he playing
this what is this just develop your
pieces so what does that look like
in this position how should we proceed
how should we proceed
yeah knight f3
or knight c3 i like knight c i would
prefer knight c3 because knight c3
protects the b5 pawn so in case he plays
a move like a6 or even bishop d7 we want
to have that pawn well protected also
maybe we'll want to play e4
so knight c3 is a somewhat more flexible
developing move okay knight f6
now
we can play knight f3 that's fine
we can also develop this bishop if we
were to develop this bishop where would
you propose that we put it
um
where would you propose that we put this
bishop slightly tricky question because
i imagine that some of you might be
thinking about g5 but bishop g5 in such
situations is not very dangerous because
of bishop e7
notice how the pawn on b5 clamps down
on this backward pawn on c7
and if he ever goes c6 then literally he
allows us to liquidate the b-pawn
resulting in us being a pawn up so i
think bishop f4
is quite nice because it puts serious
pressure on the c7 pawn and if he goes
bishop d6 then i would be very glad to
trade these bishops and either give him
doubled pawns or um you know or just
trade a pair of pieces which is good
because we're up a pawn okay now e3 is
obvious
bishop d3 ideal development for our
pieces here
yeah let's go e3
let's get the bishop out to d3
and then let's get the knight out as
well
now this is a great position for us
knight d7
the only reason i hesitate slightly to
play knight f3
those among you who are london players
should know the reason why
you just need to verify that it's okay
what kind of slightly annoying move does
black have
so it's not e5 e5 is well protected
knight h5 is what i'm thinking about but
in such in this situation knight h5 is
not dangerous at all
simply because we can either just leave
the bishop on f4
um or we can drop it back to g3 but in
the spirit of playing very positionally
in the spirit of not allowing any kind
of counter play what would be a good
insertion here what would be a good
inclusion just to make sure this isn't a
headache
um yeah let's just go h3 you can afford
it right
you can afford
a move like h3 because of how passively
he's played now you don't have to worry
about knight h5 you're gonna have bishop
h2
so
this is a judgment call you got to make
like can i afford something like that
all right knight b6
so
rather than automatically castling we
have a somewhat better move we can
continue clamping down in the center
this is basically a move that plays
itself
there's no
huge rush to castle okay b3 would weaken
the c3 knight and allow a move like
bishop b4 there's no need to stop knight
c4 that directly i'm thinking about
knight e5 centralizing the knight
and look at how we are clamping on his
position and this also discourages
knight c4 adding in a defender
okay now
again
this is much easier if you are a d4
player if you played the queen's gambit
these moves should all be very natural
to you so the move that i'm thinking of
right now is queen to c2 creating a
little battery
i am positive that many of you are
tempted to play knight c6
and
the more i think about it the more i
like it no i like knight c6 i like
knight c6 a lot
the reason i was hesitating to play it
initially
and
after the game i'm going to talk about
this concept a little bit more in depth
these very tempting moves that create
threats can look
incredibly good
but then take a look at this knight on
c6 it's supported by a pawn so you think
this is the best night in the world
right this is an amazing night but if
you look a little bit more carefully how
can black try to undermine this knight
in the future
yeah bishop e5 is excellent here a6 and
then you'd have to play a4 and that
would open up the a file
and we're talking here about positions
that are all going to be good but we
want to eliminate as many headaches as
possible so unless you have
a specific follow-up move here that
creates more threats
knight c6 is not as good as it looks
also he can play bishop b7 and chase
this knight away now what does this move
look like christian you actually found
it i'm looking at this knight
i've noticed that as a result of these
last two moves the knight on f6 has lost
the protection of the queen
so we can use this bishop to pose a
threat against this knight bishop g5 is
good even better move a really sexy move
is bishop e5 because after bishop takes
d takes the knight is going to be
trapped it doesn't have the retreat
square to d7 and the e4 square is
protected twice and only attacked once
we are threatening of course to [ __ ]
totally his pawn structure on the king's
side which in the context of the fact
that he's castled there is very
important as i've talked about many
times
and we don't have to rush with bishop
takes f6 we can also pile up the
pressure even further with queen f3
then bishop takes f6 becomes
an even greater threat
and i like that a lot
queen f3 is even more clinical because
now we're threatening to take twice on
f6 right
you know maybe you're thinking but wait
a second aren't we giving up a pawn here
well
first of all
we can take on f6
but second of all okay so he correctly
doesn't take the pawn wow because we we
would have had bishop b5 there
all right so now we don't have to do
anything at all because if we take the
knight that he takes with the queen
and
you know even though we do technically
ruin a structure it comes at the cost of
a queen trade which i don't want so what
would be a good move to hold the tension
here how would we want to hold the
tension
yeah do nothing but okay but you might
as well develop
so you might as well just
castle and then perhaps moves like rook
c1 just to support the pawn are good
this guy is good i might have to speed
up a little bit
uh rook c1 knight b5 putting pressure on
the queen side there's many ways of
doing it goes knight c4 which is not
scary because we can just take this
knight
and as a result of this trade notice how
this pawn has become a very serious
weakness right
so what should we do on the basis of
that
very sort of logical play
i just gave you a hint i just gave you
guys a very big hint
but why rook c1 is there a direct way to
attack queen e2 directly attacked upon
your first order of business should be
to ask yourself is there a direct way to
accomplish whatever it is i want to
accomplish then if the answer is no
moves like rook c1 come to mind but this
wins the second pawn
the rest is going to be a matter of
technique
no it doesn't ruin my structure it's
just one pair of doubled pawns it only
looks that way but it's only one pair of
doubled pawns that's nothing i can't
deal with particularly since now we win
a second pawn obviously
but furthermore i like the way this pawn
is positioned because it clamps down on
all these central squares so what should
we do now what's the next order of
business
next order of business is to bring our
pieces into the game
in a in an efficient
manner now which rook should we put on
d1 a rook or
or
f rook
as i
like to advise in these positions when
you're deciding which rook to put on a
square you need to take a look at the
other rook ask yourself if the other
rook is going to have a good square
uh or if one of the rooks is going to be
hogging all of the prime real estate
well if you ask yourself work 81 that
other rook is only going to have e1 and
that's a pretty lame square it doesn't
want to go there's not doing anything
there if the effort goes to d1 the other
work is at least gonna have c1 where
it's not ideal
it's not distributing the covet vaccine
or climbing mount everest but at least
it's supporting that c6 pawn
okay so we're gonna have to play a
little bit faster here um where do we
want our queen
well ideally we'd want it on a very
active square and the most active square
is e6 i like the idea of going queen a6
and potentially just going in for the
kill
with queen b7 so
many good squares there i like a6 though
um
this is
this is a winning position he's played
very very well though to hold on for as
long as he has
um
okay so
he's attacking two pawns at the same
time
and we could take and take but then he
takes and our queen gets in a little bit
of trouble so i like to move queen b5
here dropping the queen back and
offering the queen trade and
simultaneously protecting these two
pawns
so
this is you know i'm trying to play as
clinically as possible given our time
situation because i don't want this to
get a little bit out of hand
now we have an opportunity to trade both
pairs of rooks in general we want to
trade because we're up two pawns
let's do it we could even primo vrt1
because if he had taken with the queen
we would have still done that this
essentially forces the rook trade if he
doesn't trade he gives us the d file
which is a big deal
yeah i have to say this guy is this guy
is very good he's somewhat underrated
but i think we're doing a good job of
keeping his counter play at bay
i think i'll be fine with that increment
it's just that i i might have to okay so
this is a
it's not technically a mistake but what
can we do here how should we
how should we paralyze him this just
feels like a very passive move so we
should take this opportunity to
really squeeze the most out of the
position
okay it's not queen c5 because he takes
on d1 with check
yeah so we want to go queen b8 but wait
don't rush
instead of going queen beat immediately
why don't we take the rook first trading
as we wanted previously and then after
queen takes we we put the queen on b8
paralyzed him completely and this gives
us the opportunity now to move in for
the kill and what does it even mean to
move in for the kill here there's one
move that wins the game immediately what
am i talking about knight b5
now you would want to check uh no pun
intended to make sure that this check is
not dangerous it isn't king h2
and
now you could take with the queen this
leads to a queen trade and
almost for sure a win
um
and and honestly i don't see a reason
not to do that just trade queens if
you're low on time this makes it a lot
easier to win the resulting end game
right you could also have taken with the
knight but it you know now we're up
three puns
and what you want to make sure you don't
do is allow black's knight to get active
so he's probably going to go knight b6
okay where is the knight going ah it's
going to c4 so even though you're in
time pressure you can still play
prophylactic moves b3 is a very simple
move it's a very good move
because it keeps his knight at bay
now
you could go anywhere with your knight i
like knight a6 i like knight b5
i like knight a6 even more
because it prevents it paralyzes him
completely now i'm going to paralyze him
even further look at this e4 his knight
has no squares it doesn't have d5 it
doesn't have c4
it can only go between a8 and b6
and now i'm going to drive the pawns in
even further and as i'm doing that i'm
starting to think about the winning plan
the winning plan here is very
straightforward
all you have to do is bring the king
into c5 unhurriedly
unhurriedly bring in i mean if he goes
knight c7 obviously we take and we win
the pawn end game very straightforwardly
we're up two pawns
now what's going to be the winning plan
winning plan is simple you want to
create a pass pawn on the queen side
making sure that on the king side you
don't allow any shenanigans that's it
you're just going to advance the pawns
making sure you don't allow any
shenanigans one shenanigan could be h4
which with
the move of one pawn freezes both of our
pawns we don't want to allow that
so we could go g4 but i like going g3 we
can keep our options open when people
say don't hurry in the end game that's
what they mean
you can play g4 whenever you want
but um
you
might not have an opportunity to do that
if you allow him to go h4 but maybe you
don't want to do it so you keep your
options totally open
okay so we have many ways to win this
position one of them as i'll show you
guys
one of them
is going to be to stalemate his king
this is a classic winning plan in such
positions to stalemate his king
and then to force him
you'll see what i'm doing you could also
go to c5 and d6 and win but i want to
show you this particular technique
because it's nice
now here's going to be the idea the high
level idea i'm going to stalemate as
king
and in doing so i'm going to force him
to start giving away his pawns
understood and i'm going to take the
right amount of pawns in order to
continue giving him moves you don't want
to take all of his pawns because that's
stalemate you want to take as many pawns
as it takes okay so we take he still has
a move
how should we go about winning this so
why to play and win
who can tell me the actual mating moves
here
so g6 is fine we can play g6 because we
give him more moves than g7 making sure
it's not stalemate he's got this move
and g8 queen this is a little bit less
safe than the other method but i wanted
to show you what this looks like
okay
um
all right
so let's take a look
i know guys i it's all for sure i mean i
it's always under control
so this was a nice positional game now
again e6 is a move that throws a lot of
d4 players off they think man do i have
to go e4 like what is this
uh but this is just a move with a very
high uh transpositional potential
which just means that it's got some
independent value you could transpose
from this line to any other
uh
two to openings that only involve the
movie six
the most common of them is bishop b4
check this is sort of a weird bogo
indian sometimes the knight goes to e7
here
although this could also transpose into
a regular bogo indian
uh you could also play kind of a weird
bononi which could also then again
transpose to a regular bononi
so you guys get the point you could go
b6 that's another sort of independent
line delaying the development of the
knight it's kind of a hacky
weird-ish kind of opening
but there are some players who are very
well known for it
if you're if you're black you got to be
ready to play a french so if you're not
a french player this is way too risky
because you might play you might be
playing somebody who's also an e4 player
okay
so b5 is some is is honestly garbage
and
his follow-up to it was garbage too
because at least if you're playing b5
play it like a benko gambit go a6
and um
at least here you can have some sort of
counter play down the a and b files as
you do in a banco gambit
um
i'm checking to see if b5 has ever been
played before
i'm sure it has it has
it's been played in a handful of games
yuri schulman no that's a mistake
it's been played by some reasonable
players
but like some 1900s but it's
virtually never been played
so cb a6
and now um according to the engine uh
the best move for white is just to play
e4 here and occupy the center and it's
like plus 1.5
um
and after a b bishop b5
you know you have the center black
doesn't have any serious compensation
this is crap
at least i saw another one this morning
i was walking around downtown and
they had been climbing some this elitist
gatekeeper climbed up the tallest
building
and i just took him down immediately
i get the smell of elita's gatekeepers
is such a stench honestly
they're all over the place and they're
infesting american society
all right they're taking over the world
basically
uh there's the greatest they're they're
the greatest threat to
you know the global stability honestly
as the latest gatekeepers
okay um
so knight c3 knight f6 bishop f4
okay so it doesn't make sense i hope it
makes sense that you want to develop the
bishop here and not to g5
because the bishop is doing something
here it's pressuring c7 on g5 through
bishop g5 bishop e7 i'm not a i'm not a
huge fan of this situation over here
all right
bishop f4 e3 bishop d3 supernatural
development here nothing to see
again
this is a tiny bit annoying i certainly
don't want to give away this bishop for
you know
for no
[Music]
uh positional compensation if you've
allowed this at least drop the bishop
back to g3 so you get the h file for it
but black can also delay knight takes g3
and then you get into this cat and mouse
game where if you castle
then black takes on g3 and then you no
longer have a rook on h1 right
so
you always have to ask yourself if
you're bogged down on these kind of like
do i even need to allow all of this can
i not just play h3 just like you do in
the london create some lift for the
bishop
here here
knight b6 95
castling lung in no i wouldn't become
trouble castling along with white so
what can happen if you castle long
let's say black plays bishop b7
newcastle long
this move that black has played b5 is
now justified black could open up
another file a6
and
you could end up
asking for trouble here with white
notice how the b and the a files are
semi-open files
black could open up the c file with c5
so this would really invite kind of
attack
for for black
well say word
not really i mean
you're asking me i think you're asking
who does this benefit but
the h file being open doesn't benefit
anybody here it doesn't really benefit
white because you can't really get a
rook on the age file
and what i'm saying is i don't want to
part ways with the dark sport bishop
because now this just gives black the
two bishops and why would you want to do
that in the first place right
um so h3 rookie knight f3
okay i mean i'm not really commenting on
his moves he's playing fine
but very passive bishop d6
now if i were in
um
if i were playing a game against another
gm i'd probably just castle
and then go like rook c1 queen f3 make
improving moves but here we decided to
go for something
more with a little bit more pizzazz
knight c6 and bishop e5 so i this is an
important move if it doesn't make sense
let me know
but
the point is you're threatening to ruin
black's pawn structure
and essentially the bishop is
untouchable because the knight is going
to be trapped
necessitating
94 which gives up another pawn and gets
this bishop to a beautiful square
so there should be seven
now queen f3 another important move
taking immediately just not that
effective
a lot of people
go into a position like this very
commonly missed idea is this move f5
intercepting the bishop
so just always have to be very careful
about that
but if we had gone for this position
what would have been the proper way for
white to continue this is still winning
for white
um
provided that you play with
great aggression nice g4 and i think
white's got a devastating attack so
maybe this was even uh the best
uh the best approach to the position so
maybe queen f3 was unnecessary
no uh pseudoerady it's still okay to
castle this is not a disaster just to be
clear
good question is this a disaster this is
not a disaster for white it doesn't
really favor either side
this is a little bit of a damaged bond
structure but it's nothing maybe black's
not getting a rook to the h file that's
for sure right so don't have to worry
about it you don't have to change your
plans if you allow this by accident
but it's just undesirable if you can
prevent it
so takes takes now could somebody tell
me what the point was after queen takes
c6
i already said that i think during the
game though but who can remind me
what the most accurate move for white is
what's the simplest
yeah so good example of tunnel vision
would be taking twice which is good
but bishop b5 is simpler winning the
exchange
you could perhaps take on f6 first yeah
taking on f6 first is good
um gf6 then you take and then you take
and you're up an exchange in the pawn
all right
so queen e7 we castle
i think knight c4 was was a further
mistake because it allows us to win a
second pawn
if i were black i would go
rogue to b8 for example just some
neutral move
and now i like b3 quite a lot a move
that was previously suggested just to
completely limit the knight
notice the situation robert likes to
talk about when there's two squares
between a knight and a pawn on the same
file that means the pawn is
totally limiting the knight's ability to
move forward
um but here a lot of you are suggesting
rook ac1 which is a good move there's
nothing wrong with the rook ac one
mcqueen e2 just far more direct
attacking c4
black had an opportunity to play rook a
to b8 here which i would have done if i
were black in this position because
after queen takes c4 rook b2
um
black
limits the material losses so what
should i do here
what should i do in this position
and this is a great example of violating
a positional rule in order to achieve a
specific aim
yeah so rook ab1
is i think in this position very good
because yes you're tying down the rook
to the pawn temporarily but you're doing
that for a specific reason you want to
free up the queen
if black plays work before then you go
a3 the rook cannot go to a4 and so i
have to give up the pawn
so this is a great example of what i
mentioned previously which is that at
this rating
we are beginning to violate certain
rules
um or principles
because the concrete aims of the
position demand it
and you can no longer operate on general
principles alone knight a4 i don't like
because
knight a4 rook b4 becomes strong because
it attacks the knight
rook b1 is a more robust way of
defending this pawn here if that makes
sense
so yeah so that's what makes makes it
hard sometimes to find the best move so
now we want a second pawn
uh queen a6 is really nice uh pressuring
the a7 pawn threatening to go to b7
dropping it back to b5
and defending both pawns
using the opportunity to trade as many
pieces as possible okay knight c was bad
but
doesn't even really matter infiltration
knight b5 winning a third pawn
b3 notice limiting the knight stopping
knight c4
stopping knight d5
and the rest is very simple
um bring the king in okay he went knight
c7 if he just continued to shuffle
what we would have i mean first of all
you can just go to esaf and win all his
pawns but if you also want you can go
like this
and literally look at this position like
the knight can't move and then you're
just gonna bring the pawn all the way up
to b7
rook 88 saving the f rook for something
like a four
um oh you mean when i did this
wait you mean why didn't i go here say
because i don't think i'm gonna play f4
see
god and i ask
asked a good question
having seen you rip open f files with
pawn breaks why didn't you like rook 81
saving the f rook for f4 f5 so
the reason is because i'm making a
judgment call about how i think the game
is going to unfold
this judgment call might be wrong and
how many times have i put a rook on a
square and regret it regretted that i
didn't put the other rook on that score
a million times how do i think the game
is going to unfold i see that the d file
is wide open there's rooks on the d file
so in my mind
i'm anticipating a scenario where rooks
are going to get traded i don't really
see the necessity
of trying to get
this f-file attack going because i'm
already up coupons i've done my job now
all i need to do is trade more pieces so
it's all about how you think the game's
going to unfold how do you prepare your
pieces
maximally for the way in which you think
the game is going to continue and that
involves doing some guesswork and
consulting your intuition and stuff
thank you w for the prime why is queen
a6 so nice
so first of all the queens on the rim
are sometimes good
like i wouldn't really make a principle
out of it like knights on the rim are
grim queens on the rim can be good
the reason the queen is good here is
because of how much it's accomplishing
it's pressuring a7
um
which is good because that might lead
you know you can see how if you take the
rook and black takes then you might lose
the third part so that's one c over
thank you and also notice how this pawn
is very weak right on c7 the queen
could potentially migrate over to b7
and you know sort of put pressure on
this pawn
so in this particular instance this and
it's also unassailable the queen on a6
is impossible to attack with any of
black's pieces which is a pretty big
pretty big deal
if we had put the queen like on b5 maybe
black could have gone a6
um so
i just think it's it's nice for several
reasons
okay so takes rook d1 and then after
this the game is over
why not knight b5 instead of castling to
threaten the bishop um let me go back
let me see why not knife b5 instead of
castling asks
many many times over
um
oh knight b5 here
so knight b5 doesn't actually threaten
his bishop
and in addition it allows this nasty
check on b4
right and you might have to drop the
knight back to i don't really want him
it's not a disaster disaster to play
king f1 i don't really like
but why allow this kind of counterplay
you see what i'm saying and then maybe
rookie to c8
maybe ricky to see
um
yeah i'm glad i'm glad people are
learning when the night for bishop trade
occurs after kingside castles is f takes
g3 worse
well f takes g3 makes more damage to the
pawn structure
yeah like f takes g3 would also create
this backward pawn on e3 yeah that's
pretty disgusting
so
um
f3 is sometimes good when you want to
open up the f file and stuff
uh so so yeah all right guys i think i'm
gonna call it
i'm gonna call it a night um i'm pretty
tired so i'm definitely gonna be back to
so tomorrow my schedule eases up
so we're gonna be doing more as i said
monday through wednesday are my like
very intense teaching days
um then i've got more time you know
thursday friday weekend
to get stuff done and and to do more
streaming so i will do my best to return
tomorrow first half of the day i'll do a
stream
um for sure thank you god not for the
500 of course no problem it's my
pleasure
and i promise to do some more more speed
running then
um
yeah
so that's about it guys
um
and i will try tomorrow to be back
after my workout so about 2 30 p.m
eastern time i'll be back for a midday
stream
and um we're going to do some more blitz
and more speedrunning and
more fun thank you for hanging out guys
i really appreciate it
and take care guys thank you very much
uh appreciate it
goodbye for now
[Music]
you